[Musique]
zaki et hissera sont arrivés
d'afghanistan il ya trois mois
ils viennent de s'installer dans cet
appartement meublé par une association
des de réfugiés
quand les talibans ont pris kaboul en
août dernier ils ont cherché à fuir avec
leurs deux enfants
malgré trois tentatives ils n'ont jamais
réussi à entrer dans l'aéroport
était terrible tout le monde essayait
d'entrer dans les aéroports et les
talibans les frapper pour les en
empêcher
cette photo me rappelle un mauvais
souvenir
une explosion a eu lieu autour de
l'aéroport juste après que nous sommes
partis
je me sens mieux car je suis désormais
loin des talibans et je suis avec mon
mari
en afghanistan a qui travaillait pour un
sous traitant de l'armée américaine une
situation très risqué à l'arrivée des
talibans la famille a finalement pu être
évacués à titre humanitaire un statut
d'urgence qui devrait leur permettre
d'obtenir la carte verte d'ici un an
ma première impression a été de me
sentir en sécurité
et je dois avouer que j'ai été très
surpris je ne m'attendais pas à un
accueil aussi chaleureux ici aux etats
unis
en
dix mois le texas a accueilli près de
dix mille 500 afghans
la majorité s'est installé à houston où
le coût de la vie reste abordable et
face à cet afflux soudain de réfugiés
les ong ont pu compter sur la solidarité
des texans
avant nous recevions 140 réfugiés en un
an et d'un coup nous sommes passés à 140
par semaine et parfois même par jour
parlons bien du texas un état
républicain conservateur
qui se révèle très accueillants envers
les immigrés
chaque vendredi des centaines d'afghans
comme sort ils viennent ici récupérer
leurs chèques des dalles insertion
chaque réfugié reçoit 1200 $ pour
s'installer
[Musique]
le plus difficile est d'apprendre la
langue nous les afghans nous ne parlons
pas anglais
sur il est arrivé aux texas il ya trois
mois après un voyage éprouvant qui
l'amenait de kaboul à houston en passant
par le qatar est une base militaire du
new-jersey
à houston il a été pris en charge par
salle et vous mène mon domaine de
prédilection est le génie civil c'est ce
que j'ai étudié et j'aimerais que le
ministère m'aide à trouver un métier
dans ce secteur
engineering je pense que ce serait bien
de faire une formation professionnelle
peut-être pas comme ingénieur mais
commencer dans une voie qui pourrait
emmener vers le génie civil et du
challenge c'est un vrai challenge de
voir arriver un médecin et de lui dire
de faire la plonge et de ça c'est un
challenge de dire à quelqu'un qui est
ingénieur dans son pays de lui proposer
d'être voiturier vallée bras
certains tentent de stigmatiser ces
réfugiés comme l'ancien président donald
run
des personnes qui se sont rués vers les
avions n'ont pas travaillé avec nous ils
voulaient juste fuir vous allez voir
beaucoup de mauvaises choses se
passaient dans les années à venir
mais cette crainte n'est pas partagée à
houston très fière d'être une des villes
les plus diverses du pays
[Musique]
cette association protestante aide les
femmes afghanes à trouver du travail
kristen la fondatrice à évaluer leur
savoir faire et leur propose de créer
des objets artisanaux
voici les différents types de savon ils
sont tous produits par des femmes
réfugiées depuis chez elle aucune ne
travaillent plus de 20 heures par
semaine elles sont toutes à mi temps car
nous ne souhaitons pas que ces femmes
dépendent uniquement de nous nous sommes
un pont vers le marché du travail nous
leur fournissons leur premier boulot aux
états unis
kristen a déjà embauché une douzaine de
réfugiée afghane chacune perçoit en
moyenne 1200 dollars par mois ces objets
issus du commerce équitable sont vendus
en ligne et en magasin
je pense que le cas des réfugiés afghans
et particuliers je pense que nous avons
une responsabilité envers eux et je ne
crois pas que beaucoup d'américains
était satisfait par cette évacuation est
la rapidité avec laquelle ils ont dû
fuir nous pensons à tous ceux que nous
avons laissé d'abba et donc nous avons
une responsabilité morale envers eux
[Musique]
les etats unis ont déjà accueilli 78
mille afghans c'est la plus grande
opération d'évacuation de réfugiés
depuis la guerre du vietnam
farid était un interprète pour l'armée
américaine à kaboul et travaille
désormais comme chauffeur au texas
je suis chauffeur hubert
oui très bien je gagne assez d'argent
pour subvenir aux besoins de ma famille
ici et en afghanistan
mais je reste très inquiet car à chaque
fois que je parle à ceux restés là bas
ils me disent que les talibans cherchent
ceux qui ont collaboré avec le
gouvernement précédent ou avec l'armée
américaine
donc je suis inquiet pour ma famille
selon les services d'immigration il y
aurait 40 mille demandes d'asile en
cours pour rejoindre le sol américain
[Musique]